wie schauen Sie auf das was du heute
rausgekommen ist bei diesem
migrationsgipfel nach wie vor so
enttäuscht wie ich es eben zitiert habe
nach acht Monaten Vogel Strauß Politik
muss man sich über so ein bisschen was
freuen aber erschüttern das schon dass
wir seit August mit der Bundesregierung
in Kontakt treten wollen und jetzt nicht
einzelne Landräte bayerischen Landräte
waren im Herbst in Brüssel waren
eigentlich erschüttert wie hier wie in
Brüssel die Situation wahrgenommen wurde
ganz anders als sie bei uns vor Ort ist
wir haben im August darauf hingewiesen
die erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen laufen
über man muss was tun
und die Bundesregierung hatte bis vor
kurzem noch von der Ukraine als
Herausforderung gesprochen die aber
letztes Jahr im Sommer eigentlich schon
gut organisiert war durch ein großes
bürgerschaftliches Engagement und ähm
weitere Zuzug der seit ja acht oder zehn
Monaten wirklich klar ist ist eigentlich
erst in den letzten Tagen meiner
Wahrnehmung auch überhaupt in der
Bundesregierung angekommen
seit wann ist ihnen klar als jemand der
da so an der BAS is wirklich arbeitet
deswegen ist so interessant heute gleich
drei Menschen wirklich von der Basis
hier zu haben
das wird auf ein echtes Problem
zusteuern seit August
ist klar dass die Kapazitäten wie sie in
2015 geschaffen wurden mit
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen oder als über
zuerst hin sollen und einfach Klarheit
geschaffen werden sollen dürfen die da
bleiben oder nicht haben die eine
Bleibeperspektive sollen die dann in die
dezentralen Unterkünfte in die
Ortschaften verteilt werden dass diese
Struktur nicht ausreicht weil doppelt so
viel zweieinhalb mal so für Menschen zu
uns kommen wie bisher die Struktur hat
ja von 2016 bis 22 gut funktioniert da
gab es ja auch Zuzug und auch
Asylbewerber aber natürlich nicht in der
Dimension diese seit Sommer 22 gibt sie
haben das Schiff habe ich eben zitiert
einfach gechat hat da fragen was kostet
sie das jeden Monat
wir sind hier ja genau also wir sind so
bei 6000 Euro am Tag was so eigentlich
auch den Unterkunftskosten entspricht
wenn wir Pensionen etc anmieten also es
ist ein ehemaliges Kreuzfahrtschiff und
die Reederei ist auf uns zugekommen und
hat das quasi angeboten und für uns war
natürlich damals die Frage nehmen wir
eine Turnhalle Zeltstadt wie man gerade
gesehen haben oder nutzen wir das wir
haben hier keine keinen
Organisationsaufwand die das Schiffes
mit einer Crew von 20 Personen da die
sind vor Ort die kümmern sich wir müssen
keinen Ketterer ausschreiben keine
Putzdienst keine kein Essen organisieren
kein Sicherheitsdienst wir haben das
alles insoweit hier gut organisieren
können
war damals so die die Situation
eigentlich die erste
Aufnahmeeinrichtungen funktionieren
nicht mehr wie es gerade erlebt oder
erzählt habe und ähm wo kann man hier
noch mal die Menschen unterbringen wir
haben ja auch Sprachkurse alphabetis
führungskurse also es hat sich
eigentlich ziemlich bewährt sage ich mal
diese Art der Unterkunft zu den Kosten
ist es so dass ich als bayerische
Landrätin ein bisschen Glück habe weil
bei uns der Freistaat Bayern in vielen
Bereichen uns gut unterstützt und wir
zum Beispiel auch die kompletten
Unterkunftskosten ersetzt bekommen okay
ich habe da gleich noch ein paar sehr
konkrete Nachfragen dazu aber erst
vielleicht stimmt sie sagten gerade kurz
bevor die Sendung begonnen hat das was
da heute beschlossen worden ist gerade
eben alles bekannt geworden das ist ein
bisschen Zuckerguss aber mehr ist es
nicht ja also die Erwartung war nicht so
hoch aber was mich gestört hat und das
hatte ich ja auch in meinem Eingang
gesagt ist es ist das Geld sehr stark in
den Vordergrund geworden und Geld ist
natürlich eine wichtige Ressource aber
es ist nur ein Teil des Problems weil
das Geld schafft mir in meinem Landkreis
keine Flächen das Geld schafft mir nicht
mehr Personal was auf dem Markt im
Augenblick nicht akquirieren kann und
insoweit ist all das was weiter in den
Papier steht also was man jetzt noch vor
hat erstmal ja eine Ankündigung und
unser Thema muss doch eigentlich sein
und deswegen sitze ich auch hier für
viele Kommunalpolitiker dass wir relativ
zügig weniger Menschen zu uns zugewiesen
bekommen weil nur um die die tatsächlich
eine bleiberechtsperspektive haben muss
ich mich kümmern können und in der
integrationsangeboten machen das was
heute beschlossen ist ist gelten ein
System geben aber die rechtlichen
Probleme hinten dran werden nicht gelöst
das ist ein bisschen was von Baurecht
Gerede dann steht ein ganz großes
Kapitel für Digitalisierung drin da sage
ich auch das ist Digitalisierung ist ja
so durchaus schön aber unser Landkreis
ist die digitalisiert also wenn ich
warte bis der Bund Standard setzt dann
passiert sowieso nichts also ich bin
eher sage ich ganz offen enttäuscht von
dem was heute beschlossen ich habe sie
wollen ich bin so lange in diesem
Geschäft und das erste Mal wirklich
ratlos ja also Kollegin hat ja gesagt
man hat das was jetzt wir heute
diskutieren oder erleben an Situationen
das was die Kommunen vor Ort erleben das
hat man absehen können und Politik soll
eigentlich bis zu einem gewissen Maß ja
auch immer vorausschauend sein und wenn
man im Grunde im August September
Oktober letzten Jahres merkt dass es
eine fluchtentwicklung gibt die im
Wesentlichen Menschen aus dem
Drittstaaten umfasst und eben nicht
Ukraine dann muss man darauf reagieren
und das erste Ergebnis was dann war dass
die Frau Feser gesagt hat nein ich
stellt bundesimmobilien zur Verfügung
das sage ich mal im Kreis Bergstraße
herzlichen Glückwunsch Frau Feser ich
habe keine bundesimmobilien also bin ich
als Kreis benachteiligt ist das Thema
hatten wir schon mal also es gibt
sozusagen diesen diesen Mythos der
bundesimmobilie
sage ich danke für nichts
nein nein wir werden nein aber die ist
nicht wirklich geeignet also die ist
auch nicht wirklich umsetzbar das ist äh
das kommt noch dazu also diese
bundesimmobilien sind nicht alle
geeignet dafür für die Unterbringung von
geflüchteten plus auch der Bund ist ich
in dem Tempo dass man damit wirklich
etwas anfangen könnte also das kommt
noch ein Topf das zweite erlernen was er
dann kam war die zweite Ordnung die wir
wahrgenommen haben ich weiß gar nicht
was die Kommunen wollen wir haben doch
Geld gegeben und allein diese zwei
Äußerungen zeigen eigentlich das
offensichtlich nicht verstanden worden
ist wie die Situation
ich bin fast außer mir ja ich bin fast
außer mir vor Zorn dass dass wir hier
erleben müssen wie unempathisch und
irgendwie uninformiert hier über ein
Thema gesprochen wird es wenn immer die
Menschen der Ukraine in den Vordergrund
gestellt diese sind nicht das Problem so
gut ist so guter Punkt den sie gerade
machen ich habe die ganze Zeit habe ich
das Gefühl dass diese beiden Dinge
werden miteinander vermischt werden aber
das gehört eben gerade nicht zusammen
und das ist eben auch diese Falschheit
in der Diskussion die geführt wird die
Menschen aus der Ukraine das war eine
große Herausforderung wir haben sie
bewältigt weil unsere Strukturen
funktioniert haben und weil es ein stark
maßgesellschaftliches Engagement gab
genau und weil es Nothilfe ist weil
Menschen weil es existenzielles
unmittelbar bedroht waren und der
deutsche Bevölkerung sehr sehr viel
geholfen hat das hat natürlich das
System auch belastet wir haben viel
Wohnraum akquiriert vieles zur Verfügung
gestellt worden jetzt haben wir
festgestellt aber ab August September
gibt es eine Fluchtbewegung aus
Drittstaaten das ist Themen war
praktisch schon durchaus belastet und
was uns drückt ist tatsächlich das ja
Leute zu uns kommen die afghanischen
ortskräfte gesitte Mensch also Menschen
die aus Grund internationale
Vereinbarung von uns aufgenommen werden
hier bleiben Recht gegen diese Menschen
auch existenzielle Themen diese Menschen
ja haben wir und keiner von uns glaube
stellt ja Asylrecht in Frage aber
Asylrecht bedeutet auch Menschen die
Schutz suchen zu Recht dass Sie bei uns
aufgenommen werden und wir uns um Sie
kümmern können und ihnen einen
integrationsangeboten machen können wenn
ich aber so viele Menschen bekomme von
denen ich auch weiß
viele von ihnen keine
bleiberechtsperspektive vielen Dank 50%
keine keine Bleibe rechts-perspektive
haben werden dann führt das dazu dass
ich mich um keinen der Menschen die zu
uns kommt kümmern auch nicht um die
zurechtigung Asyl bitten und das erlernt
es am Schluss aus meiner Sicht
tatsächlich eine Ausführung des
Asylrechts und dann müssen wir sehr
genau schauen wie mit umgehen keiner
will Asyl in Frage stellen das ist
völlig unstrittig wir müssen aber
darüber reden wie wir dann mit legale
Arbeitsmigration umgehen ist ja auch ein
Thema was immer noch nicht gelöst wird
und es wird immer eine dritte Gruppe
geben von Menschen nicht in Gruppe eins
asylgruppe 2 legale Arbeitssituation
fallen sondern sie wenn die Gruppe drei
sind die eigentlich kein Bleiberecht hat
und dann müssen wir tatsächlich schauen
wie gehen wir mit den Menschen die
derzeit hier sind und die bekommen wir
sind das weniger von diesen Menschen die
kein Bleiberecht haben zu uns kommen
oder wie wir es schaffen dass diese
Menschen eben nicht so lange bei uns
bleiben
würden Sie sagen ist es Zeitpunkt was
machen wir mit Menschen die keinen
Bleiberecht kriegen die dann aber von
ihren jeweiligen Herkunftsländern gar
nicht zurückgenommen werden da gibt es
ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten da gibt es
ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten sind das
viele wie viel Prozent ja das ist
sozusagen das ist und ganz
unterschiedlich aber es gibt ja Menschen
auch aus dieser dritten Gruppe die hier
arbeiten die in der Gesellschaft
angekommen sind da muss man das Thema
Spurwechsel nehmen und sagen wer hier in
der Gesellschaft angekommen ist aber
dann am Schluss mal eine Bleibe
rechtsperspektive hatte oder nicht den
muss man natürlich ermöglichen dann auch
hier Teil der Gesellschaft zu werden
aber es gibt sehr sehr viele in diesen
Bereich die nicht angekommen sind und
deswegen sage wir müssen es weiterhin es
gibt viele Menschen die hier sind drei
vier fünf sechs Jahre oder acht Jahre
teilweise länger mit dudelung da muss
man sich überlegen da gibt es das
Chancen Gesetz was jetzt beschlossen
worden ist wie es gelingt diese Menschen
die Gesellschaft zu bringen aber für die
Zukunft für die Zukunft muss es klar
sein dass wir von der Gesellschaft her
nicht mehr in der Lage sein werden weil
unsere Strukturen ist nicht hergeben
solange so viele Menschen aufzunehmen
die dann am Schluss keine
bleiberechtsperspektive haben das hat
das mit Baurecht zu tun das hat was mit
kindertagesstiftung mit Schulen
einmal ganz kurz noch an der Basis
geblieben ich war das nicht klar
Hannover spielten eine wichtige Rolle in
der deutschen Migrationspolitik uns
jetzt mal so groß zu machen und da
kommen die beiden Themen Ukraine und
andere Migration kommen dann aber
tatsächlich zusammen also Flucht und
Migration kommen dabei ihn zusammen
warum also Hannover aufgrund der
besonderen Lage hatte auch schon 25 15
übrigens jetzt wieder weil wir einfach
können auch durch die Logistik gut
gelegen waren ein Stück weit das
verteilt sind um über die über das
Gelände ist der Deutschen Messe dort
haben wir die heilen haben auf dort das
ist eine Ehre halten genau genutzt haben
damals mit Zeltstädten in der Halle also
eine solche Situationen wie beim
Kollegen und das hat gut funktioniert
2500 Menschen in einer Halle teilweise
also große Kapazitäten die wir dort
aufgebaut haben einmal für die
städtische Unterbringung im ersten in
den Menschen eben aufnehmen zu können in
Unterkunft bieten zu können aber auch
gleichzeitig einen Bereich der eben die
Verteilung für den gesamten
norddeutschen Raum übernommen hat und
gleichzeitig war es aber so und das ist
ja die Besonderheit bei dem ukrainischen
Kriegsflüchtlingen dass sie eben die
Möglichkeit haben durch die sogenannte
massenzustrom Richtlinie eben anders als
andere geflüchtete frei zu wählen wo
gehe ich hin habe ich Verwandte in
Hannover sonst wo wir haben in Hannover
eine große ukrainische auch
russischsprachige Community wo eben auch
viele Verwandtschaftsbeziehungen und so
weiter bestanden dadurch sind eben auch
viele Menschen in Hannover geblieben
einfach so und auch an Sie die Frage
diese Halle was kostet sie das im Monat
also wir haben für die die Monatsmiete
lag soweit knapp 3 Millionen Euro mit
einem dummen dran also mit der
Unterbringung mit den Kosten für im
Zelte Verpflegung
Hallenmiete also alles drumherum 3
Millionen sozialbegleitung also wir
haben da wirklich eine ganze Maschinerie
aufgebaut also mit der Ausländerbehörde
die war dort vor Ort der ganze
Sozialbereich wir haben Kinderbetreuung
also der der Großteil der der Menschen
die Ukraine und Ukraine die kamen ja
wirklich vor allem Frauen mit Kindern
und da war Spielangebote tagsüber im
Betreuung also alles was dazu gehört
Märchenstunden die wir gemacht haben
also wirklich breites Angebot es hat
Geld gekostet das haben wir organisiert
das hat gut funktioniert aber das war
ihm auch die Frage also wir sprechen ja
gerade über atmende Systeme auch das ist
ja immer wieder sozusagen bei den Kosten
die Frage wir haben wahnsinnig viele
Vorhaltekosten eben auch gehabt weil wir
einfach nicht wussten was kommt jetzt
also wir haben den Krieg haben das
verfolgt dann den Bildschirm da gibt es
Kämpfe Kämpfe kriegerische
Auseinandersetzung werden noch mehr
Menschen kommen haben Vorsorge treffen
und im Grunde das ist im Grunde das
Problem der kommunalen Ebene wir sind
auch heute bei der Diskussion nicht
romantisch gewesen wir sind am Ende der
politischen Nahrungskette müssen
sozusagen das Organisieren vor Ort
absolut und wir sind nicht dabei wenn es
darum geht wie sind die Kosten wie wird
sozusagen der der gesamte auch
rechtliche rechtliche Rahmen definiert
und und auch organisiert wenigstens
können wir uns jetzt hier drüber
unterhalten deswegen ist natürlich sehr
gerne ein und nochmal aus welchen
Mitteln sie das aber sie heute hören im
Milliarde wie viel springt dann für
Hannover raus für Sie also wenn man das
runterbricht sind das so knapp 10
Millionen und wir haben allein für das
Thema kosten 10 Millionen die sie jetzt
zusätzlich kriegen die wir jetzt
bekommen würden für drei Monate würde
für drei Monate Halle reichen also
irgendwas mal vielleicht eine
Größenordnung zu nennen wir haben knapp
im vergangenen Jahr hat mir 150
Millionen für das gesamte Thema
Unterbringung Verpflegung geflüchtete
Versorgung in diesem Jahr 170 Millionen
im Haushalt veranschlagt also 717 ist
das jetzt von dem was wir auf dem Weg
waren also es ist gut das ist jetzt Geld
gibt ich habe es auch so verstanden
der erste Schritt ist und das nehme ich
auch so ernst ich hoffe dass auch die
Länder so hat es verstanden
fifty-fifty auch damit ziehen also der
Appell auch an die Länder da die
Verantwortung mitzugehen weil das was
wir dort sehen ist ja nur der erste
Schritt das ist das erste ankommen
die ganzen Kinder sind jetzt so 1.500
Menschen auf Schiffen in Zelten in
Messehallen untergebracht sind das Leben
kommen
das Personal die Person Kollektiv mit
dem Kopf das Personal haben wir nicht
auch schon vorher nicht im übrigen wir
haben auch keine Lehrkräfte in
jedenfalls nicht den ausreichend Maße in
dem Kitas haben es so gemacht dass wir
jetzt plus ein sozusagen immer noch
Kinder mit in die Gruppen gebracht haben
also ich bin auch den Erziehern echt
extrem dankbar dass sie das mitgehen das
ist sozusagen die Ebene die noch mehr
stimmt auch vor Ort tagtäglich bei den
Schulen haben mir fast 1500 neue
Schülerinnen und Schüler wie gesagt in
Hannover an den Schulen die jetzt ins
schuljahr starten mittendrin mit Sprache
lernen Klassen immens wichtig da wie
gesagt das muss organisiert werden das
muss laufen Lehrerinnen
Situation ist ja überall gleich wie wärs
wie ein Fachkräftemangel haben in den
betreuungssituationen in der Schule
an also haben sie überhaupt die Gebäude
haben sie schulen schlicht wir haben
jetzt Container nochmal zusätzlich
Container mobile Lehreinheiten sozusagen
organisiert so nennt sich das und
organisieren das aber auch schon wird
seit längerem also das Problem
schon gehabt das muss man EHRLICHKEIT
dabei sein also wir haben wenigsten
Problem ist ja nichts was gestern
geflüchteten Menschen sondern ist ein
grundsätzliches Problem auf der
kommunalen Ebene dass wir jetzt hier
nicht haben Lehrkräfte kaum haben die
Strukturen also Gebäude nicht
ausreichend haben auch nicht mit dem
Bauen so hinterherkommen wie wir wie wir
es bräuchten also wir öffnen schulen wir
brauchen Schulen das ist erstmal gut
besser als Schulen zu schließen aber das
ist jetzt natürlich noch mal zusätzlich
eine Herausforderung also auch darum
muss es aus meiner Sicht gehen wenn es
um flüchtlingsthematik oder solche
Gipfel geht dann muss das Thema
Integration das der Arbeitsmarkt die
Schule die frühkindliche Bildung all das
muss mitgedacht werden und das ist
zurzeit leider nicht der Vogel wird uns
gleich sagen woher die ganze Kohle und
die Leute und die Gebäude kommen wie es
bei ihnen ja also haben sie Schulen
haben sie was kostet sie
schulen aber das das greift alles ja ein
Stück zu kurz wir reden jetzt davon
sagen okay jetzt kommen die Leute wir
bringen die unter das ist ja alles schön
und gut wir reden ja bald nach wie vor
im Augenblick mehr Provisionen die wir
schaffen also auch das was in diesem
Papier steht bedeutet nur die Ausnahme
im Baugesetzbuch wird noch mal um 3
Jahre verlängert für den Bau von
flüchtlingsunterkünften das heißt bis 20
27 kann ich auf der grünen Wiese oder in
einem Gewerbegebiet eine
Flüchtlingsunterkunft bauen so jetzt
müssen Sie sich überlegen die baut in
der Regel zu 50% privat Investoren baut
das um und dann sagte ich vermiete dir
das dann sage ich ja drei Jahre ist die
Ausnahme regelmäßig sagt dann kein
Problem muss ich halt dann in drei oder
sechs Jahren rentieren so das ist der
erste Punkt das heißt wir investieren
jetzt das Geld in Provisorien das
Problem ist aber die Menschen die bei
uns sind von denen ja durchaus einige
auch bleiben werden oder vielleicht sehr
viele bleiben
einmal auch in reguläre Wohnverhältnisse
kommen integration bedeutet nicht nur
Sprache nicht nur Arbeit sondern
integration bedeutet auch
selbstbestimmtes Wohnen und das ist so
ein Punkt wo man sagen muss ich komme
aus einem flächenkreis aus drei Regionen
besteht Bergstraße Odenwald und Ried das
heißt wir haben dort tatsächlich dann
die Frage wo baue ich was wir haben
massive Flächen Restriktion das heißt
wenn wir dieses Thema Integration noch
angehen genügt ist nicht über Befreiung
mal für drei Jahre zu reden sondern muss
auch tatsächlich sagen wir müssen hier
auch städtebaulich über dieses Thema
einfach mal okay
andere Leute die das Bauen
das wird die Frage sein die Kollegen hat
ja gesagt wir haben im Grunde alle
dasselbe Problem wir haben
Fachkräftemangel in der Verwaltung was
die leistungsgewerbung angeht was sie
Ausländer in der angeht was die
Arbeitsende angedeutete Arbeitsagentur
die Jobcenter in den Kindertagesstätten
und in den Schulen und jetzt kommen die
große Herausforderung man braucht dann
am Schluss wenn man denn die Fläche hat
auch noch die entsprechenden Kapazitäten
um Gebäude entweder als öffentliche
selbst zu bauen oder bauen zu lassen
ganz viele Fragen an die ja genau wir
haben jetzt vorher über die Ukraine
gesprochen das sind überwiegend Frauen
und Kinder gekommen da haben wir
natürlich ganz stark dieses Kita und
Schulproblem wenn man über die seit
Sommer letzten Jahres Migration aus den
Drittstaaten sprechen dann haben wir zu
80% junge Männer da haben wir jetzt
nicht das Kita Problem aber da haben wir
natürlich im ganzen andere
Herausforderung mit der sprachlichen und
mit der beruflichen Integration weil
wenn eine Familie kommt und das Kind in
die Kindertagesstätte kommt oder in die
Schule kommt neben all den
Herausforderungen dann hat die Familie
eine Struktur dann hat die eine
Tagesstruktur dann muss die sich
irgendwo mit mit einfügen und einfinden
ist immer noch schwierig genug jede für
alle Formulare auszufüllen und als
Ansprechpartner zu fungieren aber dann
haben die irgendeine Struktur dass sie
in unser Leben kommen wenn zehn
alleinstehende 23-Jährige Männer in
einem Zweifamilienhaus untergebracht
sind dann wird es schwieriger die in die
Gesellschaft zu integrieren das macht
mir im Moment ausschließlich auf dem
Rücken der Zivilgesellschaft dazu gibt
es keine Strukturen außer derjenige muss
zu uns ins Amt kommen je nachdem in
welcher Zuständigkeit er ist und sich
dort sein asylbewerberleistungsgeld oder
seinen Jobcenter Geld abholen oder seine
Maßnahmen oder ins Ausländeramt und
diese Integration die hat nichts mit
Shift oder Herausforderung hat nichts
mit Schiff und mit selbst zu tun
jemanden irgendwo mal sicher
unterzubringen und eine warme Suppe zu
geben
darüber ist ja die letzten acht Monate
überhaupt nicht gesprochen worden es
wird über Unterbringung und über Geld
gesprochen aber was das bedeutet zu uns
in die Gesellschaft zu kommen ins Leben
zu kommen die Sprache zu sprechen in dem
Beruf zu kommen das ist die ganz die
ganz ganz große Herausforderung und da
stehen in dem Papier einige Dinge drin
von denen wir bisher noch nicht so viel
gehört haben stehen auch aber einige
drin die schon laufen in jedem
Bundesland ein bisschen unterschiedlich
aber der Kollege hat vorher von
Ressourcen gesprochen und wir sind
mittlerweile einfach an einem Punkt wo
viele Ressourcen erschöpft sind und wir
können nicht bei allen
Herausforderungen und Anforderungen die
wir in unserem Land haben sagen asylist
die allergrößte wir haben andere
Aufgaben auch noch zu erfüllen und wir
brauchen auch Ressource
und gesellschaftlichen Konsens da was zu
tun wir können jetzt darüber reden aber
wieder Weg zu uns ist und ob es wirklich
humanitäre Hilfe oder ob es normal auf
einem anderen Platz steht das ist alles
vielfältig aber wir haben Menschen bei
uns im Land egal ob die da bleiben
dürfen oder nicht sie sind da hat der
Kollege vorher schon angesprochen was
sie sind da und bleiben jetzt erstmal da
die die nicht da bleiben dürfen und
geduldet sind sind die die den größten
Ehrgeiz haben sich zu integrieren weil
sie wissen wenn sie Deutsch können wenn
sie eine Arbeit haben wenn Sie eine
Wohnung haben wenn sie fünf sechs Jahre
da sind werden sie nicht mehr
abgeschoben faktisch weil sie sich
integriert haben und Teil unserer
Gesellschaft geworden sind die die aber
da bleiben dürfen aufgrund des
Asylrechts die wollen sich integrieren
oder nicht Gott sei Dank gibt es einen
Anteil der sich auch integrieren will
aber wir haben keine Maßnahmen auch
Integration einzufordern wir können den
nicht so Integrationskurs verpflichten
wir können nicht zum Arbeiten
verpflichten nein ist nicht ist nicht
vorgesehen wirklich zu sagen wir können
das als
einfordern wir können es anbieten und da
ist für mich einfach der Punkt der das
Themas resource wenn so viel Menschen zu
uns kommen aus welchem Grund auch immer
und in welcher Rechtssituation bei
faktisch ist es sind alle da egal wie
die kommen wenn ich über die
Arbeitsmigration komme dann muss ich
mein Sprachkurs in der Freizeit machen
wenn ich aus als anerkannter
Asylbewerber Damen muss ich gar keinen
Sprachkurs machen oder ich mache zuerst
zwei Jahre Sprachkurse und geht dann
erst in die Arbeit und das müssen wir
viel viel enger verzahnen so schnell wie
möglich arbeiten lassen arbeiten können
arbeiten Arbeit einfordern um sich im
Alltag zurecht zu finden zu integrieren
und dann muss ich halt in der Freizeit
auch den Sprachkurs machen